[موسيقى]
على مدى عشره سنوات
كنت انا عباره عن مكنه بتاعت جمع اموال
كنت شغال فقط بلين في قروش
من اول سنه
كنت السنه مليون دولار
اشتغلت على مدى عشره سنوات
وبريم فيست القروشتي في افكار وايديه
الثانيه وادخل يعني كنت فقط بتبنى افكاري
الموضوع ده في مجتمع انا جاي منه يعتبر
غني
انه بيدخل مليون دولار في السنه
بالتالي بديت اشتري سعادتي
كنت بشوف سعادتي في انه انا اقدم كل ما
اشوف امي وابوي مبسوطين وسعيدين كنت انا
بكون مبسوط وسعيد في نفس الوقت
فبشتري لهم انه يتعالجوا في احسن مستشفيات
ويترحلوا باحسن عربيات ويروحوا احسن بحسب
بعد حج وبالتالي تبدا حاجه تانيه
زوجتي واولادي لازم يكونوا في احسن نوادي
ويقضوا احسن اجازات ويدرسوا في احسن مدارس
وكلهم اشوفهم مبسوطين كنت انا بكون مبسوط
على مدى عشر سنوات
كنت فقط بشتغل عشان ازيد القروش
فكانوا كل همي انه انا ما تفوتني حاجه
لازم اكبر مشاريعي ولازم احصل عليه كله
فرصه ولازم اكون على الاطلاع بكل الاحداث
ولازم ابقى على علم بكل جديد ولازم اقرا
كتب
ولازم احضر كورسات ولازم اعرف اي ترند
بينزل
فبحضر اي مؤتمرات في اي مكان في العالم
وبحضر اي كورسات في اي مكان من موانع
العاديه اللي بتمنع اي انسان يحصل على
الكورسات دي او يحضر مؤتمرات دي غير
موجوده فلوس موجوده متفرق تماما
الموضوع ده يا جماعه
اكتر حاجه فيهم كنت انا باكل في المطاعم
اكثر اني باكل في بيتي وبنوه في المطارات
والفنادق اكثر ما بنام في بيتي
وبقيت ادفع فواتير الموضوع ده زياده في
الوزن مشغوليات اكتر ولهف ولا الفلوس
وانه اوفر على قدر ما اقدر
فكان كل الاحتياج في انه كله مره انا لازم
احصل على احسن حاجه اركب احسن عربيه وانزل
في احسن فندق واعمل كل حاجه في المواضيع
دي وبقيت ضحيه زيه زي ناس كتار في تير
اسمه الفومو
الفيل وفي ما عايز افوت اي حاجه
الموضوع ده يا جماعه عباره عن مشاكل و
صراعات وتخافت على الفاضي واهداف وهميه
وسراب كذاب
كسر ابو بقيعه يحسبه الظمان هما
حتى اذا جاءه لم يجدوا شيئا وجد الله عنده
فوفاه وحسابه
بعد الكلام ده يا جماعه جات الكورونا
ويقفت الدنيا
فنادق ولا في مطاعم ولا في شغل ولا في
فلوس
ولمن جد له
الحظر في الحركه كنت لازم اكون قاعد في
البيت
فقلت لاحظتها ابوي وامي لا انا بصرف عليهم
كبروا في سنهم
امراض يصلوا في كرسي ويمشوا بتعب
بشوف عيالي وهم جايين في البيت
ما قادر اتذكر انت
فرحته بعلي في عيد ميلاده ولا بتذكر تاليا
لما انتقلت من
احتفلنا بها كيف ولا بتذكر في اي رحله من
الرحلات دي كنا بنستمتع بها كيف
في واحده من سفرياتي في جنوب افريقيا تاون
كنت نازل في كيب تاون وحنروح مؤتمر تاني
على بعد ساعه ساعه ونص من المدينه
صباح الليموزين واول ما ركبت المشوار بتاع
ساعه ونص
فتحت اللابتوب بتاعي وبديت اشتغل عليهم
بمشوار الساعه ونص ولما وصلنا السواق قال
لي
نحن وصلنا نزلت خلصت المؤتمر بتاعي ورجعت
بنفس الطريقه وانا راجع فتحت اللابتوب
بتاعي مشوار الساعه ونص لحد ما رجعت
الفندق
زملائي معاي في الفندق
فقالوا لي
شفت المنظر من الفندق لحد ما كان المؤتمر
شفت المناظر الجميله اللي شفناها قلت لهم
ما شفت اي حاجه
فصوروا هم بالتليفونات عندهم صوروا المنظر
مشوار بتاع الساعه ونص ده منظر جميل من
الحاجات اللي بتخيلها احنا في الجنه
اسكرين يا رسول هضاب مرتفعات وحاجات جميله
وحتى الحيوانات اللي بنشوفها نحن في
الافلام موجوده في المكان ده لكن انا ما
شفت اي حاجه في الموضوع ده
وبالتالي في رحله حياه طويله لمده عشره
سنوات انا ما كنت بستمتع بالحاجات لنفسي
بشوف سعادتي لما اشوف الناس اللي بحبهم هم
سعيدين
وفعلا الموضوع ده كان له زي ما حكيت لكم
فرام
في ناس كثيره ممكن تقول لو انت ما وصلته
عشان كده بقيت تشوف الوضع الاحسن من كذا
بعد الموضوع ده يا جماعه
انتبهت لحاجه تانيه
واللي هو اسلوب حياه بقى اسمه سلوفلي
ده يا جماعه انه تعيش حياتك تشتغل وتنجح
وتعمل كل شيء لكن بالراحه بالراحه واحده
واحده
والموضوع ده يا جماعه لانه نحن بقينا
بنقوم من الصباح
بنجري في هضاب مرتفعات خلال اليوم سعيدين
وحزينين سعيدين ومبسوطين وغيره لحد ما
يخلص اليوم وياها 200 نرجع البيت عشان
ناخذ راسنا على المخده واول من خط راسنا
في المخده يبدا
التفكر واتجاهات طموحي وامالي وحاجاتي
فتروح عليك حاجات كثيره جدا تلغي نفسك
ساحرته طول الليل
الموضوع ده يا جماعه بقينا حاسين انه نحن
بنجري ولا حاجات ما مفهومه وما معروف
هدفها وين او طموحنا نوصل وين
الله يا جماعه بيقول لك اشتغل وانجح واعمل
قروش وكل حاجه بس خلي بالك من جوانب حياتك
زبلان كثير يا جماعه زملان كثير حوالينا
بيقول انه هم ما بيتذكروا كل تفاصيلهم
تفاصيل حياتهم في بيوتهم انه اولادهم فجاه
كبار وهم ما عارفين هواياتهم ولا استمتعوا
معاهم بحياتهم ولا اي حاجه وما لحقوا
يستمتعوا بها وحاليا بقوا على وش جوازنا
بيقولوا
احد عمالقه
بيقول انه دائما بنسمع انه تايمز ماني بس
انا اعتقد انه الكلام ده غير صحيح اطلاقا
لانه يا جماعه الوقت اغلى كثير من القروش
والدليل ببساطه ان القروش
ممكن
ترجع لها او ترجع عليك لكن
الزمن ما بيرجع واذا خسرت عشان اتاكد لكم
الموضوع ده فكروا معي في خدتك كلمه القروش
في اي حاجه ممكن نستغنى عنها كليا او
جزئيا زي مثلا الشهره والكرير والنفوذ
والمكان الاجتماعيه والوجاهه لو خدته كمان
في الوقت كل شيء
عنه زي صحتك اسرتك وذكرياتك
حتلقى انك محتاج تطبق القاعده
تبعته اعتقد معظم الناس يكونوا عارفين
عنها لكن خلوني اقول سريع انه عشرين في
الميه مجهوده بيؤدي الى 80% من نجاحها
وارباحه واربعه في المئه من تفانيك في
شغلك بدي 64% من النتايج واربعه في المئه
بتقدمه بيؤدي الى 50% اللي بتحصل عليهم
انت بس محتاج تركز على المهم
وتشتغل عليهم بذكاء بروقه كده والخواجات
بيقولوا في الكلام ده لسه
في الحديث الشريف بيقول ما قل وكفى خير من
ما كثر والهى
شيل رجله شويه من الابنص
وتفرج في حياتك وانت ماشي هدفك أنحنا يا
جماعه لما يكون ماشيين احنا هدفنا بنعيم
بس تجاه هدفنا انا عايز اقول لكم وانتم
عشان هدفكم افتحوا القزاز بتاع العربيه
وعاينه من الجانبين استمتعوا بالمنظر
استمتعوا بحياتكم انتم عايشين في الاتجاه
ده
لحد ما توصلوا وانا افضل ليمي اليوم مره
انه انا اوصل متاخر شويه ومبسوط اكتر مني
انا اوصل بدري ساعه وساعتين وشايل امراض
ضغط وسكر وامراض كثيره جدا جدا
فلازم فلازم نعين لو جوانب حياتنا ونحن في
اتجاهنا الهدف شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]